I don't know why does my mind to go to
drugs immediately with all of these kpop
is a drug I know that kpop is loud and
wild and fun occasionally I will turn on
the kpop radio station on Spotify
I've watched a couple of Big Bang videos
and like junior high
I know it's wildly popular in Korea I've
never heard of kpop slang before so this
should be a learning experience pretty
confident that I know zero kpop site
what is Gangnam style technically kpop
or that's literally all I know buy it
this is a real word so that's why I'm
struggling maybe this is like a sick
beat in kpop like man that bias was so
sick maybe it's like when you're
listening to a new song by a k-pop group
and you know what kind of music they do
already so your bias is like you already
know how the music's gonna be I'm gonna
say like a hater
if someone's showing bias they could not
be a fan of something else right your
favorite member of a k-pop group that
makes a lot of sense I mean it does have
to do with the English definition of
bias that is amazing I will be
incorporating that into my everyday
vocabulary visual visual probably means
like who's the hottest person of the
group I would say your visual of the
group oh okay sure the hottest member of
a k-pop group a visual is when you are
swayed to like a new song more by the
dance moves in the music video then the
music itself attractive like hot blah
blah blah super visual visual was the
member was considered the most
attractive by the ideal set of beauty
singer isn't that how most boy bands and
girl groups are like put together
there's always that one person
high-touch fool man a song that spans
the reach of many generations maybe
that's like you wave to somebody and
then you give them a hug or someone
super super tall and you like tap them
on the head cuz high times I feel used
to feels like top of the line when like
your
a group member does something cool
you're like that was so high touch this
is when a kpop band reaches you very
deep inside of yourself like you really
have a lot of feelings I was high tide
just by a fan service where k-pop idols
stand up with their hands out and fans
line up to die I'm gonna give them a
high five so they stand up they go like
this right and they're like oh yeah I
totally got it trash trash is the member
of the kpop band that's like they're
just the worst in every way possible
they're not good k-pop fans man that
song trashed meaning it sucked a song
that you secretly liked that other
people hate when you have an unhealthy
obsession with a particular group and
you acknowledge it
so like I'm trash with BTS Taylor Swift
trash k-pop slang is fun I've learned so
many new words now it is creative it
knows no bounds and I think I'm gonna
start using it I guess I wasn't
expecting real words I don't know what I
was expecting
they're pretty close to the actual
definition I was expecting a lot more
like weird words hey you're trash hi
judges actually doesn't really [ __ ]
[Music]